[Music]
hello and welcome back to the roads 2000
as always my name is Caleb bendy and I
will be your driver on this journey and
reading through the YouTube chat here
before we got the show started first of
all hello to everyone watching hello to
Adi hello hello glad to have you guys
here but also very exciting news I think
this is the first ever confirmed case
right oh yeah gammy has confirmed that
he was below 2000 before he started
watching the series and he is now above
2000 so there you go
proof it works proof the method works
anyways
tonight we're gonna be going over some
very exciting games of course right now
the world has kind of stopped but chess
has not there are a ton of super fun
online events with some of the the
world's best players still going on
right now
chest comm is actually hosting the
nation's Cup which is a pretty
interesting event featuring mixed teams
each nation and or I think there's a
team Europe in a team rest of world
bringing three players of any gender for
the top three boards and a female player
as well to each round and I'm having a
lot of fun following these games also
notably legendary chess player Levon
Aronian
is coming back to play in this
tournament and it's hard not to root for
that guy speaking of he played a really
great game in one of these rounds of
this Nations Cup now obviously I'm
rooting for the United States as well
but in this game Lenny a dominguez
actually fell victim to Levon Aronian
and this is what gave me the idea for
tonight's lecture topic it is a game
which features a very interesting attack
on the king however it does so without
the Queen's it is an attack on the king
with the Queen's off of the board and
there are actually a ton of really fun
games that really go to show just
because you get the Queen's off does not
mean the game is going to be boring does
not mean the game's over does not mean
you're relegated to a boring end game it
just means you have all the other pieces
to look out for so why don't we get into
it pretty quickly here yeah
efore e5 Knight f3 Knight f6 Knight
takes e5 the Petroff one of the main
lines we have d6 Knight f3 takes back on
e4 of course well-known opening mistake
is to take here on e4 of course you get
met with Queen e2 and things get a
little more complex after the move Queen
e7 and Queen takes e4 but definitely not
a good opening line so black inserts
this move d6 to remove this Knight from
this e5 square before recapturing just a
little Petroff background for you now
white claims the center with d4 this is
more or less than mainline these days
when players are really playing for an
imbalance position trying to take out
the Petroff you'll see them play this
nice Knight c3 move it's a pretty
interesting one it is what Fabiano I
think has been playing against the
Petroff recently fought and who knows
better how to beat the petrov and then
the pet shops or one of the petrov
finest players ever
Fabiana Cara Juana of course the idea is
after takes generally D takes and you
get some quick development with this
Bishop anyways though we don't see that
in this game we see d4 black of course
responds with d5 and you get this
interesting fight for the center Bishop
d3 by white is trying to highlight that
this Knight cannot stay on the e4 square
we have Bishop d6 by black very
symmetrical castles castles and then
this is where white really starts trying
to prove that there is something to play
for in this position it looks kind of
similar to maybe some exchanged French
positions that you guys might be
familiar with but of course White's try
for the advantage is not to develop
calmly with moves like c3 but rather to
challenge blacks claim in the center
with the move c4 and that is exactly
what Lenny a Dominguez does here now
after c6 this is kind of the one
imbalance we're going to see in this
position White has the slightly extra
Queen side space with the pawn on c4 and
black is on a slightly more defensive
approach defending this pawn on d5
rather than going after White's pawn on
d4 immediately Eleni a continued with
Queen c2 and sorry excuse me Levon
Aronian it plays this move H sick
and this is really where it LaVon
deviates from the fairly standard theory
here this is a line that has actually
been tried and we'll talk a little bit
more about that later but h6 is an
interesting way to just take away this
g5 Square from any of the white pieces
for example if the move Knight f6 were
played on the previous turn perhaps the
move Bishop g5 could even be considered
as a good move here moves like this
definitely so h6 just takes away some of
these squares removes this pawn from the
threat of capture and gives black a
little bit more freedom now of course
the downside is you do just leave this
knight on e4 rather than capture meanie
me immediately excuse me Lenny eight
plays the move rook e1 Vaughn develops
with Bishop e6 and now after C takes d5
C takes d5 Lenny a says enough is enough
you didn't defend your knight on e4 you
didn't move it out of the way I'm going
to take your pawn and he does exactly
that and this is the interesting
position that Levon Aronian got out of
the opening now this one I think is
fairly new stuff I did manage to find
one game at least in this position that
actually went pretty terribly for black
black kind of got demolished there and
I'll talk a little bit more about that
once we get to where we deviated from
that game so thus far we are actually
following exactly a game from the 2020
moscow open that was played by two
players by the name of Abdul Sadr of and
Sudd juanny so for those curious we'll
take a look at that as well Livan
continues with the very nice move Bishop
d5 and this is where you kind of start
to see blacks compensation appearing
White has an extra pawn it is this extra
d4 pawn in the meantime black is getting
some immediate play with these bishops
now this Queen steps over to g4 and
black now continues with a rather
counterintuitive move generally you
would expect with these nice looking
bishops on the open board and being down
a pawn black would want to keep the
ladies on the board but this game goes
to show you as well the other games
tonight that Queens are not required to
launched an attack on the king so here
White's queen is actually a far more
active piece than blacks Queen and so it
is just objectively the best move to
play Queen d7 and trade those Queens now
we have Queen takes d7 and it takes d7
nothing really better for white moving
the Queen over to age four it doesn't
really make a ton of sense and now
Knight c3 by white it is conceivable
that you could play a move like 95 but
you're just gonna run into one or two
threats like rook e8 spinning this
Knight and at the end of the day you
might even end up giving a pawn back if
you're not super careful
so instead Knight c3 was Lenny eight
dominguez's choice now the obvious
downside to this move is Bishop takes f3
and G takes f three and this is where
Levon Aronian deviates from this game
that was played at the Moscow open now I
can't speak with a hundred percent
certainty for the players but I'm pretty
sure they were both well aware of this
game as they tend to keep up on the
relevant games happening around the
world these top grandmasters do so let's
take a look at what happened in that
other game first and maybe that can help
us understand how Levon Aronian decided
to play this position so in the other
game between abdul Sattar of and suwanee
rook f d8 was played it's a perfectly
natural move black wants to get opposite
this pawn on d4 white plays the move
Bishop e3 black starts to reroute this
Knight to f8 looking for perhaps this f4
square white plays your key d1 another
natural move supporting the pawn from
behind and then after a few more moves
Knight g6 rook c1 rook c8 well now white
comes on the board with this move Knight
e4 and the fact of the matter is after
takes on c1 and takes on c1 this Bishop
is just in the way for black and black
now spends time moving it back to b8
so it's a full tempo doing so and now
after Knight c5 b 697 well it's it's
gonna turn out that this Bishop is in
the way again the black rook will
to stay on this file it needs to stay on
this file to guard against this pawn
advancing but now it simply cannot
because of the awkward placement of this
dark-squared bishop
so now Rick f8 and after d5 white went
on to in a very very nice game here that
I'll show you just super quickly this
pawn just comes up the board the white
pieces are in total control and this D
pawn is a huge thorn in black side white
then sacrificed a rook on c7 and at the
end of the day these two pawns ended up
being far too much for black to handle
I'll let you guys analyze that one on
your own time but white did go on to to
win this endgame fairly easily using
these super far advanced pawns
so that brings us back to this position
here now if you remember what was played
in that other game that I just showed
was Rick d8 and some moves like this and
what happened was this Knight came into
e4 at this Bishop this Bishop went back
to b8 and that Bishop ended up being a
little bit of a target for white so if
you're Levon Aronian here having seen
this game previously having perhaps done
some homework what do you think the move
is that you're going to come up with
here you've seen how some of these games
kind of transpire here when things go
poorly for black so what can you do to
solve some of these problems in this
position what can be done
well getting a lot of positive feedback
in the chat it's great to hear that you
guys are always improving at chess of
course you can't attribute that to any
one source it's just you get better at
chess with time just get better with
time
why not Bishop b4 says kite one two
three and that's exactly right Levon
Aronian plays this move Bishop b4 and at
first glance it looks counterintuitive
right because superficially this is a
really great Bishop on d6 it's standing
in the way of this pawn it's keeping
pressure on this isolated h2 pawn it's
guarding some Queens side squares and
this knight at first glance doesn't
really give too big of an impression but
in fact Levon Aronian correctly surmises
that this night is going to be worth
more than Bishop then this bishop in
this position this bishop simply gets in
the way as we've seen from practical
experience so Bishop b4 is the move that
Levon Aronian comes up with here just
removing this Bishop from the threat of
capture and ensuring that this Knight is
not going to be as big of a problem as
we saw in that previous game so Bishop
b4 is a great move by Levon Aronian
let's see Bishop d2 comes on the board
and now
Levon continues with rook F to d8 note
that well we do want to get rid of our
bishop being in our own way we're not
really interested in fixing White's pawn
structure like this so Levon definitely
not going to make that trade so after
rook d8 Lenny 8 continued in a similar
way to the previous game with the move
Knight e4 perhaps trying to get this
knight active the good news now for
LaVon is he's gotten rid of this
annoying bishop on d6 he's gotten rid of
the target for this Knight
so this Knight now comes with much less
threatening with much less threatening
presence in fact Levon
simply trades on d2 and this Knight is
relegated back to this d2 square for the
moment in a purely defensive posture
that's so Levon solving these opening
problems in a really interesting way and
I hope you guys at home can take away a
little something from that
if you play your own games that's the
most common way to kind of gain this
kind of experience you don't necessarily
have to study all of the games that that
go on but if you see a wine played in a
super tournament and align that that
you're familiar with a line that you
play yourself and it goes poorly for
your side it's definitely worth taking a
look at that game seeing what went wrong
for the side that lost and seeing if you
need to amend your own openings in
return so that's exactly what Levon
Aronian does here he sees this game
happen he sees what went wrong for black
and so he he solves this problem and
then he tries it out in his own game
with great success so especially in your
own games if you end up losing getting a
bad position out of the opening try and
understand why that happened and try and
see if you need to make some changes to
to what you're playing and that's the
really instructive thing from Levon
Aronian here noticing that this bishop
is a bad piece and getting rid of it
before it becomes a problem now
Levon is free to continue with the move
Knight f6 and in stark contrast to the
last game it is only black who controls
the d5 square and thus with the pawn
stuck back on d4 it's going to be a much
bigger weakness than it is an advantage
you know it's not ever threatening to
Queen
if you can't ever cross the d5 square
that being said black is still down a
pawn so all is not totally well now the
move Knight b3 comes on the board for
white and I'd like you guys to try and
guess
Levon Aronian 'he's next move it's a
very natural move it's another very
instructive move so I'll leave it to you
guys to try and find this one
I always want to hang on to my bishops
old school well that's that's fine but
if you know in a particular position
that your bishop is simply a target then
that's when you can start trying to
think well maybe I shouldn't be be
holding on to this guy okay
I've given you guys some time to think
there are some various ideas in the chat
a five is one suggestion rook c8 95 two
of those are really natural moves really
instructive moves this a five move is
something I've recommended in the past
against Knights on v3 and the reason
I've recommended it is because with the
move a five you often threatened to
shake this Knight loose and force it to
two squares and doesn't want to go to
the difference here is that in fact the
knight does have a square it it wants to
get to immediately so with the move a
five you're actually just increasing the
power of this move Knight c5 remember
that last game this Knight went to c5
and to b7 and then white ended up
winning the game with with some finesse
so I don't know if Knight c5 would be
the move immediately but perhaps it is
just a little bit too slow for example
if rooks c1 or rookie seven even got
played then after a four this nights
gonna step here gonna start creating
some threats of its own remember this is
in fact actually an extra pawn for white
so if you play b6 and ninety four white
is not super upset about ending up in in
some position like this where probably
this is this is just going to be a draw
but white does have a slight edge in
rook activity here it's gonna take you
some time to get this rook on a eight
into the action maybe what even has
better there but I don't totally love
that move a5 the move LaVon went for is
a move I did see suggested in the chat
it's just the move b6 this Knight comes
to b3 it has two squares that it can
potentially hop to and move b6 takes
away both of them it's a great
preventative way to play against Knight
there's some famous quote I don't
remember how it goes or who said it so
probably I shouldn't brought it up but
it's about playing against Knights the
way to play against Knights is to take
away their outpost to take away their
forward advancing moves if they can't
advance then they become rather passive
rather worthless as is this Knight stuck
on b3 and that's really the the
difference of the story of this game
versus the story of that first game we
branched off to look at from the Moscow
open this Knight is now an awful awful
piece and this Knight is now free to
wreak havoc rook ASC 1 is White's choice
a totally natural move now
of course white is trying to invade on
the seventh rank black plays a very nice
move 95 a very preventative chess from
Levon Aronian here and it's it's working
with great effect white kind of finds
himself without much to do and as such
white plays this next move a3 obviously
not the most impressive move perhaps
Lenier is playing with a similar
strategy of preventing the Knights
forward maneuvers of course a3 is
keeping an eye on the B Foursquare this
Knight not going to land there anymore
but of course this Knight has other
options as well and this is blacks
compensation this weakness on the Kings
side when you get a weakness and
structure like this it's not necessarily
always about being able to capture these
pawns it's about the squares that are
weakened by it
these h3 h4 f 4 squares even the f3
square all become very very weakened
when the Jeep on disappears so a3 now
just more natural chest by Levon Aronian
rook d6 you lift this rook you prepare
to double you increase increase the
pressure on d4 and you even potentially
hint at going after the king don't
forget the topic of this lecture so
rookie 4 played by white natural oof
guards this epoch ARDS this deep on
rather and perhaps hints at some
defensive ability moving laterally rook
88 now and lennie a sensing some danger
on the Kings side tries this move King F
1
to get a little bit closer to the center
now you guys at home did have a good
idea I just didn't like the order you
put it in so b6 first prevents this
nights before word hops and now the move
a5 does come on the board with threats
of a for threats of kicking away this
night so that was in fact a good
positional idea you just have to get the
order right sometimes now of course a
four would be a really good move for
black for example if white just passes
then a four night back Knight f6 and
this pawn is already going to fall so
white plays a for himself simply from
preventing this idea now of course the
downside of this is it gives up another
another horsey hop another hop for this
horsey now if your Levon Aronian it is
your time to shine here so try and come
up with another really great positional
move by Levon Aronian
this is how attacks are created not by
superficial threats but by gaining
positional edges around the king by
gaining positional advantages and then
transferring them into a concrete attack
a material edge and advantage and
activity these these things and this is
what Levon does so expertly in this game
so black to move what can you come up
with what is the topic the topic is
attacks without the Queen's attacks
without the Queen's
ah the chat is filling me in on my
horrible miss codes earlier the quote
about playing against Knights apparently
that is by Steinitz
I just remember the content I don't
remember any any of the specifics so I'm
a I'm at esos says f5 Toblerone also
says f5 and yeah f5 is actually not not
the worst idea here this rook is on a
pretty nice square stationed on Eve 4
and you would very much like to kick
this rook off of this square I think the
problem here for black is that f5
actually gives up a more critical square
than efore of course by pushing this
pawn you give up more squares now with
f6 being a legal Ricky 5 I think is just
going to be a very nice very active
square for this rook and you might have
actually hemmed yourself in with a
little bit of a weakness here note we
don't really want this pawn on f4
because it's taking away this square
from some other pieces that might use it
to better effect so not f5 here not f5
Suba Keira seems to have it a lot of
people saying kb4 I'm assuming it
meaning night before night before is
going to come at some point in the game
but I think first this move g5 should be
played as was mentioned in the chat so
g5 is a really really great positional
move it is locking down this weakness on
on f3 here locking down this f4 square
and ensuring that white is going to be
saddled with these double pawns for
quite a while if you do play some move
like night b4 I'm not sure if you can
really do it immediately but perhaps
white can start considering moves like
f4 himself trying to get a little bit of
extra space with this pawn over here
make it actually useful for something
most like 93r probably what you had on
your mind but even here I think white
can start considering moves like like
rook c7 giving up this b2 pawn and going
for some shenanigans actually I'm
second-guessing myself now probably the
move
see two would have to be played and
perhaps you know the more I look at it
the more I like your guys is night
before move after night before wait
probably has to stop
93 if I had to guess and then maybe you
could continue with g5 but I like the
move g5 immediately not saying night
before is bad move the more I look at it
and it actually does seem totally
reasonable but the the positional way
the principled way to play is this move
g5 locking down the f4 square and these
two weak pawns on f3 + f2 white now is
in a purely defensive posture and plays
the move rook c4 simply over protecting
this pawn stepping out of perhaps these
same night d3 tricks that you guys were
trying to enact now King g7 a simple
improving move from Livan takes his time
here he has a really great positional
bind and so he is playing it slowly
letting his opponents make some more
decisions and this is another thing that
super grandmasters will do that is
slightly difficult to replicate they'll
uh if I can make more quotes they'll
give you enough rope to hang yourself
with if I can use a brutal quote so
Levon Aronian does a really mean thing
with King g7 where he says hey it's your
turn
play a move hint so of course Lenny a
does play a move with rook e1 Levon now
continues taking his time just plays
King to g6 playing more improving moves
and now after Knight d2 perhaps this was
one retreating move too many for Lenny a
Dominguez Levon Aronian now springs into
action with the move Knight before as
you guys were suggesting it is a great
move spying some real weaknesses in the
white camp and at this point it comes
with the added bonus of attacking a d4
pawn as well so Knight b3 was Lenny his
choice just bringing the knight back to
defend this pawn but now 93 does come on
the board rookie - and now Knight f4
comes with tempo so just a little bit of
finesse there rather than come to Knight
up for immediately he comes here with
tempo comes here with tempo and then
comes here with tempo so at the end of
the day Levon Aronian
gaining a tempo
by making the full circle so Ricky one
comes on the board and now let me ask
you your Levon Aronian you seem to have
improved your pieces too
you know almost the max here right
you've doubled the rooks in front of the
week isolated deep on you've brought
your knight to the most active square on
f4 it can come to d3 whenever it likes
harassing the struck your opponent has
just repeated moves essentially you know
saying alright alright man you got me
here let's let's let's repeat so the
task is now on you to come up with a way
to increase the pressure to continue
playing for a win so try and come up
both with a specific move and perhaps
with with an improving plan idea for
black here how do you try to win this
game
how do you try to win this game
how would Magnus have won this probably
hopefully in a similar fashion to Livan
Livan played it very very well
so I'm seeing some specific moves what
about long term where do you want all
these pieces long-term and feel free to
be a little bit unrealistic about this
now I know I'm asking for a ton of
people to say well put the rock on h1
but you know long-term plans long-term
plans we know this is a weakness we know
this is a weakness perhaps b2 is even a
little bit of a weakness are there any
weaknesses that we're kind of neglecting
to mention weaknesses that look at first
glance slightly difficult to get to but
also seem even more difficult to defense
there's one point in particular that
Levon Aronian really focuses on here
so I'm seeing some moves now truck f6
rook d5 or well Rick t4 is it a bit much
okay looks like that was a typo he
metric d5 Knight back to D 3 well that
would be repeating this is the position
we just had and then LaVon brought the
Knight to f4 96 puts more pressure on
the D pawn to be sure however I will let
you in on a little secret I don't think
this is going to be a winning endgame
unfortunately this one looks to be
rather drawn so just winning the D pawn
is not going to be enough here so these
ideas of f5 and age 5 I think are
actually doing a little bit more harm
than they are good it's nice to have a
little bit of shelter for your King at
the very least and then rather than do
things the traditional way of attacking
on a side of the board where you push
the pawns forward and you like increase
the pressure with the pieces behind
LaVon chooses to put the pieces in front
of the pawns here and this is kind of a
future of a position with slightly less
pieces on the board you know if there's
a ton of bishops and knights on the
board it doesn't make so much sense to
strand your rooks that in front of your
pawns
but with a single pair of knights and
two rooks on the board this type of
strategy it can work very well it's a
nice little feature of these types of
positions with slightly less pieces
where it does give the attacking side
actually a little bit more freedom to go
a little bit wild so as someone said h2
is a weakness this is the one that I was
really hoping you guys would get so
LaVon starts to enact a plan where
instead of keeping this knight on f4 he
imagines well what if I had my rook on
h4 what happens then with a rook on h4
suddenly things become very very awkward
for my opponent to defend this h2 pawn
king g1 is really the only way and then
you can really imagine rook number two
joining the party and all of a sudden
things get get a little bit crazy so the
first move to start with as a lot of you
said is going to be this move rook f6
spying this f3 pawn 92 is lenio
dominguez choice trying to
keep an eye on this guy now we see LaVon
play the very nice move Knight d3
hitting these two guys rookie to
slightly more natural way of defending
does not work anymore due to the
placement of this night so rook b1
instead and then LaVon wastes no time
rook to f4 is his move now as often
happens in chess there is no victory
without risk
rook f4 is of course actually risking
quite a bit here it's allowing white to
play this move rook c6 check now the
King steps back to g7 and rook takes b6
so white taking off this b6 pawn in
return of course black is getting this
d4 pawn and now white plays a a slightly
nonchalant move here that really does
more or less secure his fate perhaps
slightly better for white a better try
it would be to play a sacrifice with
this move pawn to b4 now if we get
Knight takes b4 white can try Knight b3
for example your d3 and 985 and White's
going to end up with an a pawn you know
it's not a lot but it is nape on you
know something to play for
to counteract black's huge pressure on
the Kings side and also has the added
bonus of getting rid of blacks final
pawn on this Queen side instead Lenny
and Dominguez plays this a slightly you
know soft move as they say
pawn to b3 just a little bit too slow
for what this position calls for here so
now if your von Aronian it's time to
start finding some knockout punches so
what is the big tactic for black here
big tactic for black
Toblerone says white is dead here
he's not wrong
he's not wrong night takes up two is in
fact the tactic played in the game and
now black is actually reached material
equality and taken away actually what is
a key defender in the the white camp
with this f2 pawn gone things start to
become very awkward for this white king
of course if you take on f2 black will
regain the peace immediately on D to
take over here on h2 perhaps and with
the entire Kings side falling this is
going to be a very good endgame for
black and in fact I dare say it is just
going to be a pretty simple win for
example or it could be five would
probably mean Yorick h3 if you don't
defend this guy I'll take both of these
pawns if you do to offend this guy I
might even play this move I don't know
if I will play this move these end games
are a little above my head instead
though a better try for white is what
was played in the game the move King
eetu defending this night now I'm sure
all of you guys at home can find the
move here if you want to take a second
try you're welcome to but of course I'm
revealing it now the move is rook h4 as
we said earlier this h2 upon a
devastating weakness in the white camp
the white king is really the only piece
that was capable of defending the square
and now that it has vacated to e2 h2 is
quite simply falling why it puts in the
effort though with Knight to f1 and now
it's just a question of coordinating
blacks remaining pieces to attack this
white King well Vaughn does so very
masterfully he plays Knight e3 heading
back for the f4 Square rook b5 means
Knight f4 with check King f2 is White's
choice trying to keep an eye on this
trying to perhaps run back all the way
to the Kings side and now rook d1 really
highlights how strong these three
remaining pieces for a black are a
knight on f4 is devastating the rooks
now coordinating together to get at f3
and white is totally busted here rook c5
was Lenny a dominguez try and now I will
let you actually at home try and find
Levon Aronian 'he's next move
what is Levon Aronian 'he's next move
and white hopefully you guys at home can
spy in this one it's it's a pretty fun
move actually it's a pretty fun move
it's a pretty fun one it's it's a slick
one
all right I'm not gonna wait the full
delay for the chat to find it I'll trust
you guys
it is of course the move rook c3 this is
a fantastic move of course the problem
for black you can't get at this King on
the second rank this Knight is guarding
both of these entry points so what is
LaVon do well his opponent just played
rookie five so he says okay I'll play
rook c3 now you can go ahead and solve
this threat in this threat you know take
take your time it's it's all you buddy
go ahead of course Lenny a dominguez
can't solve both of these threats he
plays rook takes a5 and rather than the
immediate check with some escaping
chances perhaps out one way or the other
for this for this white king Lenny a oh
sorry LaVon simply plays rook h3 hitting
this f3 pawn now rook b5 was letting A's
move and of course this pawn is just
falling rook takes f3 king g1 now rook
c2 comes on the board and this king is
dead this King is just dead rook b6 rook
F F to a5 rook G to check King h1 and
the final move of the game the
devastating mating Nets does everybody
see it it is of course the move Knight
h3 with the dual threat of rook g1
checkmate and if this Knight moves out
of the way rook takes h2 checkmates
Levon Aronian taking down millennia
Dominguez in this very exciting Nations
Cup battle here I had a lot of fun
analyzing this game and it really shows
how to coordinate the pieces around this
King side weakness here you know a lot
of players I think would get to this
point and and end up just quite simply
drawing here it looks like White has
successfully defended all of the weak
points beef d4 is defended b2 is well
enough defended by this rook he's got
this open file he's got chances for his
own activity if you get a little bit too
crazy but LaVon coming up with some
maneuvers to really take
lynnie a dominguez here it was it was a
very very fun game so that is the first
game I wanted to show you guys we spent
quite a while on it because it was a
really great one why don't we move on to
another game featuring a queenless
attack now this is one by two fantastic
Hungarian chess players from a long time
back this was the 1984 Hungarian chess
championship I believe it was a game
between poor Tish and Pinter probably
not saying either of know those names
correctly but a poor Tish was of course
a world-class player from Hungary back
in the 80s he competed in the candidates
tournament I think multiple times he
earned himself the nickname the
Hungarian Botvinnik I think from my
Wikipedia research prior to this class
and his opponent Pinter was no pushover
either enter a multiple time Hungarian
champion so why don't we see what
happened in this game of course it
started d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 Knight f3 d5
Knight c3 and we have the tirage game
with the move c5 black immediately
challenging White's claim to the center
in the most combative way possible now
of course what commonly happens in these
structures is somebody ends up with an
isolated pawn in this case after C takes
d5
we have Knight takes d5 efore claiming
the center Knight takes c3 B take C 3 C
takes d4 C takes d4 and with the way
that's both sides of plate there's not
technically an isolated pawn on d4 but
rather we get a a groom felled type of
structure where black has not really
committed this bishop to the g7 square
and has also committed this pawn to the
e6 square and so this does change a few
things about this structure for one of
course the move Bishop g4 is now highly
illegal can't play that one secondly the
pressure on the d4 pawn superficially
seems like it's been lessened by this
bishop not being on g7 but in fact black
does create some mounting threats
against this pawn anyways with threats
like Bishop b4 check in fact Bishop b4
is in fact the main move here in fact
but instead ninety six played in this
game with the threat of Bishop b4 to
follow white chooses the line with
Bishop c4 and then black gets to play a
really fun move here that is the move b5
so of course b5 if Bishop captures there
is a fork so after b5 this Bishop simply
steps back to e2 and now black does
continue with this move Bishop b4 check
after Bishop d2 you can't quite
tactically justify taking this guy just
yet
because it does leave your Bishop on b4
hanging so queen 8th life played in the
game
we have Bishop takes b4 check by White
definitely not the most common move here
this is probably where modern theory
more or less diverges there is a really
fun move d5 for black that has been
played at rook b1 is also commonly
played the move a4 as well kind of
highlights the b5 may have been just
just a touch premature
by black here but instead Bishop takes
b4 is quite simplifying
after Queen d2 way if Bishop d7 a3
forces the Queen trade on black or white
sturms rather we have take some d2 takes
on d2 and a6 solidifying this pawn on b5
and this is the queenless middle game
that we have arrived at here and so now
the the question for black is going to
be how do you try and take advantage of
this slightly
exposed King sitting on d2 your queen is
off the board so it's going to be a much
more difficult task than than normal so
the way to go about it here for black is
simply to think about ways to open files
your rooks are your heavy hitting pieces
that you have left so you want to find
ways to get your hook into the rooks
into the game specifically to get at the
white king in the game white starts with
the move a for breaking down this Queen
side
structure a little bit further and after
b4 white tries a pretty interesting move
here after a four if white just plays a
normal move like rook c1 perhaps sorry
you know let's let's actually say like
Griff d1 instead perhaps the move
a5 is is going to be good for black here
the idea being you shore up this
protected passed pawn on the Queen side
and that's going to be a more or less
permanent advantage that black and half
going into this endgame however the move
rook hc1 might do a good enough job of
preventing this with threats like Bishop
e5 in d5 to follow even ninety five
coming on the board here perhaps work
agency when it was slightly more
accurate a5 also of course attempts to
stop the move a5 from black simply by
making it illegal you know that one
works as well so now we have this
interesting dynamic over here both sides
kind of saddled with a weakness but
we'll see that blacks weakness actually
turns out to be quite useful for him
with some nice control of the c3 square
black continues now but the move rook d8
like I said it's all about the rooks
here black is looking to find ways to
get at this King to rip open in this D
file the move King III comes on the
board and now if you've been paying
attention you'll realize that I've been
saying over and over again it's all
about opening files so with that big
hint in mind I'm going to leave it to
you guys at home to find blacks next
move how did black open files in this
game
how did he do it
Jim is suggesting short castle
Rick d8 with King e7 maybe and nobody
yet has spied the move okay
ROG seems to have the move it is of
course the nice move f5 this is the
highly combative move by black to open
up files in front of the Kings to get
the rooks into the game to take
advantage of this King's exposed nature
and even in fact opens up this diagonal
for the bishop as well this is the
activity gaining move played by black
now of course this is the type of move
that you only want to play under special
circumstances this is one of those
special circumstances f5 is a hugely
weakening move and the number of
drawbacks that come with playing a move
like f5 often outweigh the number of
advantages that come as well for example
here
you have to have a plan for what happens
on the move e5
so hopefully you all at home see the
plan for black after e5 it is of course
just to play this move f4 divert this
King from the d4 pawn and this is going
to be pretty nice for black you can even
keep the pressure up with a move like g5
threatening f4 at a later date so e5
leaves this D pawn behind that's why
that one's not getting played and so
this week ecig spawn is not going to
stay on a six for loan he takes up five
played in the game
he takes f5 by black as well and now the
nice move Bishop a sea floor and now
this is where the game kind of turns
into a special one this is kind of why
this one is a classic blacks next move
actually is fairly natural Bishop c4
prevents castling black needs to get
this rook into the game so black plays
the move kingi seven now I'm going to
kind of give it away by telling you that
black played a really cool move here but
white plays the move d5 trying to use
this deep on to his advantage and now
I'd like you guys at home to try and
find blacks next move here
it is a lot of fun it's a lot of fun
what black did in this game
it's a lot of fun where black came up
with here what do you guys got what do
you guys got for me hey rook takes d5 is
a little bit much it's a little bit much
giving up a big one they're giving up a
big one can't can't do that one can't do
that one
okay it looks like some people do have
it now the move rook e8 is actually what
might be the best move it has an
identical idea to the move that was
played in the game King f6 with the idea
of rook e8 to follow so black simply
sacrifices this entire night here on c6
gets this rook into the game and after
King efore see if you can find the
correct follow up for black what is the
follow up here you've sacrificed your
knight are you simply going to recapture
this piece is this what you're going to
settle for I wonder I wonder what you
guys at home have up your sleeves
alright I'm not going to wait too long
in this one don't want too many huge
pauses so of course the move played in
the game is rook e4 check going after
this King immediately and getting a
losing position so rookie 4 check was
actually a slight misstep in the game by
black the best move is actually the
really fun move g5 check here the idea
being you're quite happy with where this
rook is already and this is the rook
that you want to get into the attack so
g5 is sorry distracting this Knight
that's the word can come up with it for
a second away from the d4 square and
after a move like rook d4 check now if
you step here it should take c6 is check
if you step here rook rook g4 is check
and after King takes you can even play
Bishop takes c6 here with some threats
against sorry this pawn on g2 as well as
this night sitting here on on the g5
square and it's going to be rather
difficult for white to handle all all of
these threats for example if Knight f3
oh well that that also the bishop
singing is well don't forget that the
bishop singing as well so that was
actually the best line rookie for played
in the game instead and after King g3y
it just might be getting away with it
now black does a really fun thing here
rather than recapture on c6 he notices
that the Kings only save squares seem to
be on this diagonal right now and so the
move Bishop c8 is what black comes up
with a great practical try here
rook a c1 by white guarding this bishop
on c4 now we have rook g4 check King h3
and f4 now there is only one way to win
the game for white here so far white has
defended well against this huge
sacrifice here but you have to come up
with a really special line now in order
to win this game so you guys at home I
encourage you to try and pause your
videos here try and find the way find
the way to survive with white and not
only survive but in fact end up winning
this game note that if you play like any
move at the very least there's going to
be this nice perpetual check for black
not to say black wouldn't have more
after a move like Bishop e2 but at the
very least there's this perpetual check
so your task with white is to stop this
check as well as to you know win the
game so not only survive but also but
also win so Bishop takes a6 actually
does not do it for the same reason I
just mentioned this double check is
going to be a drop the lion actually
goes one the move c7 this rook will move
out of the way if you start giving these
checks king h4 h5 well now white can
actually consider in this position
simply running up the board simply
running up the board of course white
couldn't do that in this line because
here the move rook d5 was going to be
checkmate
without this bishops support
so c7 and the white king can run up the
board if you try to give these checks if
you move the rook then this move Bishop
e6 is the killer point bye-bye
white here you interfere with the
bishops communication with this rook if
rook takes while now King takes g4 wins
this rook if Bishop takes another killer
move by white rook c6 pins this bishop
to the king now these threats still do
not work due to this rook being
interfered with so you can give these
checks but the white king will still run
up and Rick takes c6 it's going to be an
unstoppable threat really crazy stuff
there that is the only line that
actually wins the game for white
understandably this was missed 95 played
instead and this is a pretty fun one
here it tries to avoid these perpetual
x' by guarding the g4 square but now
black plays not the best move but
definitely the most fun here so black to
move now black to move and win black to
move in win I'll show you the best line
and also the line that that was played
in the game
a disgusting engine line well I mean it
is just the only way to win which makes
it fun in my opinion of course it's
going to be a difficult one for humans
to see but Bishop e6 is really a
beautiful beautiful move you can call it
disgusting you can call it beautiful but
it's it's pretty crazy stuff in this
that's what I like to see there should
be six just planting this bishop in the
way so rook g3 check is actually going
to be checkmate here king h4 and there's
only one move that wins this is in fact
in the best line and this is a really
fun move as well if you've noticed this
rook would love to come checkmate the
White King however there's a pawn on the
way
so the oh well I guess okay sorry rip g6
wins as well I didn't notice this the
first but the best winning line is to
play h5 with the idea being after
White's next move you're going to play
g5 force the White King to take your own
piece and then rotate shape is checkmate
and the engine actually just says h5 is
is simply checkmate in six here ninety
six is somehow the best move guarding
against this I guess and then you're
gonna end up in the same fate shortly
after a few checks so h5 killer moved
there however if you don't see that
hopefully you guys at home came up with
the move played in the game yeah some of
you have it it is the nice move King g5
defending this rook using the King as an
attacker we love to see it
now if Knight takes rook Bishop takes is
a checkmate
Knight f7 check played instead king h5
keeps this King in the attack of course
with the Queen's off the board
perhaps black was thinking you know why
not bring the other monarch into the
attack and that's exactly what he does
here and now white is simply dead he
comes up with the only try to and now
I'm sure you all at home can see the win
here for black there's only one there's
only one win once again once again a
crazy position
all right hopefully you guys at home see
it of course you need to unpin your rook
or else you might in fact lose this game
so rook d3 check trying to divert this
bishop away from the defense of the king
if Bishop takes rook g3 is a double
check mates
note that you're nice attacking King has
taken away the only flight square for
the White King so you cannot take g3
played in the game and now another
really great move by Pinter here is the
move f3 once again just taking away the
only flight square available to this
king
now if Bishop takes rook rook h4 is
going to be the checkmate with this
square taken away as well as the g3
squared taken away the only move to keep
the game going it was actually Bishop
takes f3 when after rook takes f3 and
King g2 for example rook takes f7 and
black is just going to be up a full
piece so understandably white did not go
for this line instead giving rook c5
check now of course rook g5 is check
counter check g4 is check counter check
counter check Bishop takes g4 is check
counter counter counter check um King g3
and now F takes G to check was enough
for resignation from from white year of
king g2 Bishop h3 is checkmate if you
play King f4
well then Rick takes c5 is winning
enough winning enough so that's a fun
end of the game there rook c5 check rich
g5 counter check g4 counter counter
check that should takes g4 counter
counter counter check
- in fact win this game so just to show
you the power of getting out a check
with check they're really really fun
game here but between poor Tish and
Pinter a Hungarian classic I'm willing
to say perhaps our current resident GM
Dennis boorish is familiar with this
game as well alright there's five
minutes left in the show there was one
question about this game that I did want
to talk about back here I believe I
asked you guys for ways to open up lines
here and someone should
to the move g5 g5 I mean it's it's a
nice idea trying to provoke Knight takes
d5 and this in fact would be pretty nice
for black to get the center pawn for the
G pawn but white simply doesn't have to
take this and in fact after the move h3
this the square is as well guarded and
then you're going to have to continue
with f5 anyways if you want to achieve
anything and these threats aren't going
away so g5 not totally ideal there okay
with that in mind we have four minutes
left I wanted to pull up a final
position for you guys this is of course
a game between McHale tell and I've
gonna Mukhin perhaps mukhin thinking he
could get away with the draw against al
by trading Queens early they arrived at
this position okay I just gave it away
this position unfortunately II five was
a killer move by tau to open up the D
file and after Bishop takes Bishop to c5
I'm hoping you guys at home can find one
last final tactic play a like tile
checkmate the King without the Queen's
on the board here what can you do
okay one last puzzle for you guys at
home before we we go away here you don't
see counter counter counter check in
every game you got that one right
got that one right so of course the move
for everybody at home is not to trade
bishops but to play rook takes d3 and
this is the the killer blow by tally
here he sees all these pieces lined up
on this D file he gets ready for it he
says I want to kill this King 'if I've
forces this bishop away either by takes
or Bishop c5 and now Rick takes d3 is
the killer blow King takes d3 the only
move really for white here if you take
here well this should be five comes on
the board anyways and this night is
going to die so King takes d3 Bishop e5
is check King c2 now Knight a four
increases the pressure to this Bishop
King b3 b6 forces this bishop away if
Bishop takes here well that's going to
be a checkmate by my math
my math correct my math is is correct
enough it's it's going to be checkmate
eventually with Bishop d3 so instead
Knight c4 after takes takes rook C one
night to c5 check King takes b4 a6 is
the move that forced resignation in this
final game that I wanted to show you
guys of course
the threat is more or less unstoppable
and what is the threat I hear you asking
is of course Knight d3 check with just
just winning all all of the rooks pretty
hard to stop if you do move this work
out of the way
well then still 93 check and and Knight
takes e5 this is going to be enough for
tau so didn't have a ton of time to show
you guys this last game just wanted to
introduce that that kind of final fun
tactic I recommend checking out that
game between Afghani mukhin and McHale
towel on your own time if you're
interested that is going to do it for
tonight on the road to 2000 hopefully
you guys enjoyed these queenless attacks
these fun checkmating attacks without
the Queen's on the board I had a great
time analyzing these games that is going
to do it for me on this class tonight if
you're watching live stay tuned for the
endgame class coming up directly after
if you're watching the recorded version
thank you so much for joining me my name
is Caleb Denby and I will see you next
time
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]